Something happened to Iris. Barry how
could you do this for God's sake I'm
your wife. You're not my wife.
The real iris is out there somewhere.
I won't let her down. Fine you want to see who I
really am. I'll show you.
Hello Joseph you're a hard man to get
ahold of that's on purpose.
Wait!
I just have one little thing I need from you.
An apology.
Seriously. That's what this is about? I
wanted to help the world. Now you're
destroying it.
I am keeping it safe. You let me rot in
here while you took everything I created.
I had a vision for humankind. So did I!
And now I'm making it a reality.
This is your last chance Joseph.
Threats are for real people Eva not
phantoms because that's what you are.
And me,
darling
I'm untouchable
Literally.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash trailer video for
the next episode seventeen I'll explain
what's going on with the canceled
episodes in the rest of the episodes
this season Grant Gustin already
explained what their original finale is
going to be so they're re working that
for the beginning of season seven now so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and let
me know what you want them to do with
season seven
everyone queue up all your godspeed in
red death posts there were a couple good
things that happen during this week's
episode but some of it was a bit of a
slog so i'll talk about the really big
stuff in the reverse-flash the god speed
stuff the red death stuff first then
I'll talk about some of the Easter eggs
from this episode everyone just wants to
hear about the really big stuff first so
no worries so what's happening is the
flash finale is actually going to be
episode 19 now because they had to stop
filming because of the virus when they
were in the middle of episode 20 so they
didn't finish that episode Grant Gustin
talked about their epic cliffhanger that
they were going to end on he said there
was supposed to be some kind of epic
reverse flash teaser in episode 22 the
last time we saw him was when they were
talking about creating the new version
of the Speed Force and we saw his
negative Speed Force energy leave STAR
Labs in search of another body to
possess they literally say in that scene
that he'll be back he's just searching
for another body.
Thawne's gone for now. Right. Thawne's
tachyons might have dissipated but they
weren't destroyed. Which means he's
not dead. Just formless. He's probably out
there looking for another body right now
like a red eyed pissed-off Voldemort
When comes back we'll be ready.
So the epic reverse flash cliffhanger
probably would have been him finding
that new body in because of all the
Dragon Ball Fusion speedster episodes and
scenes this year that's probably how
they were going to create the TV shows
version of Red Death reverse flashes
negative Speed Force energy fusing with
another speedster of some kind and since
they still haven't paid off the god
speed teaser from season 6 episode 1 my
assumption is that either they're going to
turn August heart into a bigger
character during season 7 finally or
they're introducing their post-crisis
rebooted godspeed and they'll use him as
part of their epic reverse flash twists
Grant Gustin did a livestream with the
DC people the other day he implied that
the story that they had to cancel for
this season all the stuff they were
going to do they'll just pick up at the
beginning of season seven so they'll
still do all that story just to wait to
the fall to get it he did say that they
still had a good cliffhanger that they
were going to end on in episode 19 and
because the god speed episode is episode
18 in the title of episode 19 his
success is assured my assumption is that
it has something to do with mere masters
grand plan to go after joseph carver and
black hole and team flash trying to
create that new version of the Speed
Force during his livestream Grant Gustin
also talked about how big of a new 52
comics fan he was the really interesting
twist with the Speed Force that they had
during the new 52 is also the idea or
the concept that Barry Allen from the
prime version of Earth the main version
created the Speed Force himself it
flowed from him into all other realities
of the multiverse so maybe they'll try
to work in some Easter eggs from the
comics for that kind of stuff where the
idea that our Barry Allen starts to
create this new Speed Force when he runs
around I really like all the big
mythology stuff that they do with the
Speed Force and the other speedsters on
the TV show so I'm surprised that they
didn't address any of that during this
week's episode but it feels like this
week's episode was mostly just an
elaborate excuse for Jesse Martin to
leave the show early before the end of
the season so I'm going to take a knee go
into witness protection I'll be back for
the finale
all the mirror masters stuff that
they've been doing has been a bit of a
slog to get through but I did like the
SU did nice stuff with Ralph I know her
name is sue Dearborn on the show but
she's sue did knee in the comics because
they're already together we all know
where this is headed so let's just call
her sue did knee they just named this
actress a series regular for next season
so I'm assuming that at some point later
in season 7 they'll become an actual
couple they were mostly using her for
James Bond jokes during this week's
episode some of you may have even
spotted the Batman V Superman referenced
during the episode when they go to the
bank Sisko talks about keeping people
busy while they're trying to hack this
information it's meant to be a parody of
the scene where Batman is trying to
steal information on all the metahumans
from Lex Luthor at that big party that
they go to early in the movie we find
out the reason why sue didn't he is
trying to rob all these banks is that
she's not actually robbing banks she's
just going after black holes banks
because they've been extorting money
from her parents who are super rich and
she's trying to save them the other
really big reveal from the episode is
that chief Singh who's now Chief of
Police is actually another one of mere
masters duplicates running around trying
to keep people from stopping her from
taking down Joseph Carver if you're
confused about what the new mirror
master is actually after because all she
talks about is going after Joseph Carver
but she has bigger plans as they implied
during this episode remember she's
supposed to be one of the villains this
season they still haven't done a good
job of explaining what it is exactly she
wants to do once she stops Joseph Carver
what is her plan why is it so crazy and
why does Joseph Carver sound like he's
so determined to keep her trapped in
there to protect everyone else they just
want to make it seem a little more
interesting and complicated but everyone
let me know in the comments what do you
think is going to happen with
reverse-flash what was that original
epic cliffhanger that they were going to
end on in the finale and what do you
think is happening with Godspeed this
season the good thing about god speed is
that was actually supposed to be episode
18 but I don't know if he was going to
be in more episodes before the end of
the season or if it was just going to be
episode 18 but because they filmed that
we'll actually get that episode the
other really big thing that nobody has
actually been talking about recently
that I've seen is that grant gustin's
contract is up after the flash season 7
so unless he burnoose his contract
season 7 will be the final season of the
flash he hasn't said anything about
wanting to leave the show so I'm
assuming he will sign on and they'll do
a season 8 if he didn't hear it Stephen
Amell also talked about the final season
of arrow and how he basically wanted to
quit after season 7 and wanted the
season 7 finale to be it like nope I'm
done
no more arrow episodes that's it the
reason why he's signed on for season 8
is because he said they backed up a
dumptruck of money so big that in his
words it would have been irresponsible
to say no to coming back I do think it
was mighty cool of him to be honest
about that came back for season 8 mostly
because of money not so much because he
was really excited to do more arrow
episodes but he did want to end the show
on good terms for the fans so he does
really care about the arrow fans it just
sounds like based on what he said that
by the time they got
to arrow season seven he felt like
they've done everything they could with
the character and there wasn't really a
point in doing more episodes but because
you have crisis on Infinite Earths and
they wanted to make Oliver this big
character turn him into the spectre
reboot the universe he was such a big
part of their plans so then he came back
he's signed on and we got our crisis on
Infinite Earths Grant Gustin also did
talk about the new Superman TV show
that's coming he said he's really
excited for that so maybe they'll do a
lot of flash and Superman crossovers
during season seven in season eight but
everyone let me know in the comments if
the flash goes through season seven in
season eight who do you want the
villains to be for season seven in
season eight I've got some new Marvel
and Mandalorian videos that I'm working
on but everyone just leave your video
requests in the comments below as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all the videos
when I post them every one click here
for my brand new venom 2 teaser trailer
video and click here to learn about that
cool black flash suit that Grant Gustin
was wearing thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!